[Music]
it's just we should call it George
Washington's on coke
yep that's the alternate title for the
piece anyway this is how they make their
money for example senator Mitch
McConnell did you know this seventy
percent of his money comes from
senatorial salary twenty percent of his
money comes from speaking fees ten
percent comes from winning races against
the hare study was Royce SIA SIA we
actually find out her income break down
there SIA 20% comes from album sales
forty percent of her money comes from
touring 40% from swiffering Hugh Jackman
check this out Hugh Jackman 50% movies
that star Wolverine that makes sense
30% movies that feature Wolverine and
20% movies that could have used a little
more the old Wolverine to be honest God
we found the income break them for dogs
in yeah dogs Inc this 40% stuff they
find on the ground 60 percent teaching
fees from Trump University
[Applause]
sarah palin we found her income
breakdown sarah palin 20% is gee whiz
all sorts of stop 30% garsh i don't know
Persephone's gotcha pie charts anyhow
[Applause]
Alexander Hamilton 20% I have no income
I died in 1804 30% have you no shame sir
let the dead rest in peace 50% fine I
get a piece of the musical Broadway
t-shirts Capital One CEO Richard
Fairbank
yeah look at this 30% salary 70% asking
people what's in your wallet then when
they laugh and say oh I've seen those
commercials that's the company you work
for right I say yes it is now what's in
your wallet at this point I stare at
them menacingly and then they hand over
their wallets I then run away and keep
the money
and finally Melania Trump we found her
income breakdown yep
1% modeling 99% marrying
[Applause]
why
you